[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with pr consultant
alex dean and director of the demos
think tank polly mckenzie they'll be
with us from now until just before
midnight so let's see what's on some of
those front pages for you now
the times looks at simon case's
departure from the investigation into
downing street christmas parties
the mirror covers the same story their
headline party probe office had a party
the telegraph also looks at the fallout
of the cabinet secretary's removal
simon case stepping down from the
investigation puts pressure on number 10
according to the guardian
the express urges people to put faith in
boris after a week that says has left
the tories down but not out
omicron infections now out of control
reads the front of the eye as cases of
the new variant continue to surge
the financial times also leads with
omicron their headline omicron no less
severe experts say
now cut the 10-day rule is the headline
of the daily mail as there are calls to
return to seven-day isolation
and the star predicts snow and more
covid on christmas day
with me tonight pr consultant alex dean
and director of the demos think tank
polly mckenzie welcome to you both and
let's start with the
telegraph and this is the story about uh
fresh leaks uh potentially derailing the
prime minister's bid to move on from
that by-election defeat alex
it seems that the prime minister number
10 cannot get past these um issues over
parties and allegations over hypocrisy
and as a lot of the fronts say
simon case's departure from the
investigation over the allegations
concerned
are really i think quite harmful
there'll be some people who try to say
that this is a westminster bubble story
but i think it's not i think that this
is a real issue for number 10 to get a
grip on i thought the prime minister's
apology today taking personal
responsibility for the by-election
defeat in north dropship was the right
note to take and i think he's going to
have to take personal responsibility for
the investigation into these parties as
well
polly what do you think
i wasn't enormously impressed by the
prime minister's apology today in that
kind of extraordinary interview with
your correspondent sam coates
actually the prime minister said
uh he takes full responsibility for
everything that happens in the
government because he and the government
didn't persuade the journalists not to
focus on parties
and that's an odd kind of way of taking
responsibility for him it seems to be
all about a kind of media management
strategy
and for me it's the fundamental thing
there is an absolutely cast iron
guaranteed way to stop the media talking
about your bad behavior and it's not to
do the bad behavior
unfortunately there's no way to go back
in time and
deal with this issue
but you know it that's why it's so
difficult to deal with because it really
does speak to the character
of both the prime minister and his
leadership and the staff and the people
he puts around him i mean it's
completely absurd to have put simon case
in charge of this investigation into
what parties happened when he himself in
his office seems to have hosted or
enabled to go ahead a party which may or
may not have been a breach of the rules
we don't know but certainly is at the
margin of what is or isn't allowed and
it's interesting because some of the
commentary around this seems to be
questioning whether it was reasonable or
not to have those rules in place and
whether it should have been all right to
have a party gathering after work
amongst colleagues who were already
spending the day together and that's a
reasonable debate but it's a reasonable
debate for us to have had last year
those were the rules in place it was
very clear you should not have a work
party or social gathering and so for the
people who put those rules in place to
have broken them is extremely serious
the person who's going to take over this
investigation from simon case is sue
gray who is forensic and formidable used
to be uh the director general in charge
of propriety and ethics now second
permanent secretary at the housing uh
and leveling up department and you know
i think we can have quite a lot of faith
in her but the problem is that the prime
minister that's why i do agree with alex
the prime minister is going to have to
accept that he permitted either a
culture or that tolerated that level of
wrongdoing or that he directly permitted
those parties and saying that you take
responsibility for that it's about more
than just blaming the media for
reporting about it alex
hang on i i agree with some of what
polly says i of course agree with the
praise for sue gray and i think that
she's the right person to take over but
the simon case was definitely the right
person to appoint because his cabinet
secretary the issue for me now on these
stories is twofold first of all if simon
case was at a party that was uh alleged
to have been in breach of these things
he surely would have known that and he
should have recused himself at the
beginning rather than now i can't
believe that people are sitting around
waiting for somebody to say hang on
weren't you at one of these before they
say oh okay i've got to step back from
it but the second point is that no one
seems to have argued from the government
perspective including those in the last
week myself included who've been
defending boris and the prime minister
that london as i recall was in tier two
at the time which permitted work
gatherings and it seems to me that that
seems to be the way out for a lot of the
discussion it doesn't look good but that
was within the rules as far as i recall
yeah the times now looking at the uh
future investigation and polly the
question has to be
whether the public will have uh any
confidence in in future investigations
into these parties
i think it's quite hard for people to
have confidence partly because it's
genuinely complicated um
there's a lot of different parties
there are i believe there's supposed
parties that may have occurred in the
downing street flat there's parties that
occurred uh within downing street within
the office area there's potentially
simon casey's party there's allegations
that there were parties uh at the
department for work and pensions and i
i've lost track and i'm supposed to keep
up with this stuff so
for an investigation to
go through all of those in a systematic
way to collect all of the evidence
um
you know in a in a patient and
considered way
will is necessary but even then it's
just it's quite hard to get over that
hump of public opinion which comes out
of the sense of chaos and confusion that
has reigned over all of this and that is
public that is public opinion that's
being reflected within the conservative
party the ft uh reporting uh about angry
conservatives warning the prime minister
he could be out by mid 2022. alex do you
think that might be the case
i don't actually i don't think that the
letters are going to be flying into sir
graham brady but i do
think that polly was right about that
sense of of confusion and
i think that it played a significant
part in the north shore by-election
results i thought the front of the times
captured these things well um the the
person appointed to oversee an inquiry
into these parties the one that polly
forgot was the one at cchq allegedly and
the one that led to sean bailey stepping
down uh from one of his roles um in
london uh the the the case that's been
made on the front of the times um is
that you appointed this person to
oversee things and now that person's
having to accuse himself well that's
right because for the last week we've
been pointing towards simon case as a
figure of authority who can oversee
these inquiries and number 10 must have
known or at least simon case himself
must have known that he couldn't with
authority oversee that given that he was
in attendance allegedly at one of these
parties himself so it's very tricky but
no i don't think actually that these
letters will be going into uh
graham brady not least because a large
number of conservative mps owe their
seats to boris johnson he after all won
the 80-seat majority that the party now
enjoys in parliament so government will
now be wishing desperately just to get
to christmas have a fire break between
all these events in 2022 and have a
reset next year
polly very quickly can the prime
minister keep the support of
his party the daily express saying doubt
but not out why we must put faith in
boris
yeah they're quoting jacob bruce mogg
who's kind of trying to rally the troops
i think alex is right it's unlikely that
this will lead to uh to direct the
resignation of boris johnson or or to
him being ousted by his mps but i do
think it's potentially the the beginning
of the end for for his popularity with
those people and if covet continues to
get worse if inflation continues to get
worse if there isn't kind of light at
the end of the tunnel in terms of the
government actually achieving things
that pressure will worsen let's continue
with the eye shall we start with that
one this section uh and that
front page looking at uh the infections
rates of omicron um
doubling every one and a half days in
london and northeast of england alex
well it depends on what you think out of
control is it's definitely true that
omicron is more virulent and that london
as the least jabbed area of the country
is experiencing this worse than some
other parts but it does seem that the
assertions that we received when we went
through our vaccination program that
vaccines were going to
break the connection between infection
and hospitalization still remains
broadly true
so we are having many more cases
reported as the front of the eye says
but given that we are testing at twice
the rate we were testing last week or a
year ago if you make the annual
comparison that's not that surprising
the important thing will be whether
we're seeing an uptick in
hospitalizations or sadly in deaths and
so far at least
what would you say out of control would
be how would you measure that
well that's my point if the only
consequence of people being infected
with omicron is that they get infected
then that actually given that we're all
going to have coronavirus sooner or
later doesn't matter too much the thing
that matters to our country is whether
people have to go to hospital or whether
we would get seriously ill and if we've
broken the connection between infection
and hospitalization then actually people
getting coronavirus given we're all
going to have it isn't the main thing is
it
polly do you agree with that
i do it's just that the numbers now for
omicron appear to be getting so large
that even though we have the vaccines in
place and have been doing a phenomenal
work uh in terms of the booster program
that there is a real danger that those
hospitalizations which are starting to
creep up especially in london deaths
which aren't yet but we know that that
is a a lagging indicator it takes time
for people to go from catching the
disease to getting very yell through to
getting into hospital through to losing
their life so we know that takes longer
it just what the
medical scientists are telling us is
that those numbers are starting to look
really very worrying and of course it's
often we hear this sense that oh the nhs
is obsessing about covid and it's
forgotten about heart disease and cancer
and strokes and diabetes
actually it's
it's that if omicron gets out of control
if we have those hospitalizations from
covid that eats up capacity of the nhs
and reduces its ability to think about
cancer and heart disease and
and
it's wider services to the community so
i think you know there just there is
this risk now that we are going to see
numbers which are beyond what the nhs
can manage easily very quickly i just
want to bring alex in on the daily mail
front page and this cutting of the the
isolation days that's been suggested
very quickly we've only got about 20
seconds sorry
suggestion that we should reduce the
isolation required if you are um pinged
or if you're if you're sick and i think
that must be right given that in the end
we've got rid of our red list most of us
are going to get coronavirus sooner or
later we've got to get back to normal
and some of that's got to be reflected
in a reduction in isolation times